House Republicans about to give the
Biden family a financial colonoscopy
ouch I know Congressman comr says he's
ready to send subpoenas directly to
Hunter Biden and the president's brother
James those could arrive as soon as this
week we're guessing they'll probably
want to ask about the series of shady
Financial transactions uncovered after
looking at the Biden's bank records
including this $200,000 check that James
wrote Joe and this $40,000 check which
many say is the commander-in-chief
getting his 10% cut of his family's
foreign income the White House brushing
those off as just loan repayments but so
far has refused to release evidence that
backs that up comr says that's just the
tax trick that they
use we can connect the dots because as
you as you showed on the screen with the
series of transactions that's called
money laundering and this was a very
organized criminal Enterprise by the
Biden family and the reason they did
these these uh complicated transactions
was to uh disguise the source of the
revenue and to deceive the IRS from
paying taxes so what you're going to see
in the coming weeks is a lot of loans
anytime the bidens have money they're
going to claim it was a loan because you
don't have to report loans on your
taxes that comes as the prosecutor who
tried to give Hunter Biden that
sweetheart plea deal testifies before
Congress David Weiss claiming that
politics played no part in the hunter
probe Harold you claim to be a lawyer um
you know I I'm still not sure who Trump
defrauded and what went on there but
this is absolutely so clearcut
disguising The Source avoiding paying
taxes through these interest free loans
come on Harold this is like so easy and
yet the media can't grasp it but you can
it doesn't seem like anybody so I'm
that's a theory that Mr comr has and he
if he can back that up with evidence uh
then perhaps a justice department or
others will will pursue a case uh if he
has I can't even pronounce uh after what
we talked about here in the in judge
what's a what's a subpoena it's under
you know
what so they if if if these things are
to be believed that they're 20 or 30 of
them they're going to call the family
before we we we'll get an opportunity to
see but I do think I don't leap to
conclusions because people write checks
to one another uh and um I don't leap to
conclusions because someone says that
it's a loan repayment I look we we had a
conversation at the break about the law
and about what happens when someone is
charged with an assault or a
manslaughter homicide the same is true
with these kind of instances if there's
evidence to back this up then uh uh Mr
Mr comr has something but if there's no
evidence this is a theory of the case
that he has and we'll have to wait to
see if it can be proved so he's guilty
thank you Harold judge this loan thing
and the fact that they they're interest
free this is like a a common tax cheat
isn't it yeah pretty common uh in my
experience in addition to the whole
Biden look there's nothing more
important than putting to rest a claim
one way or the other that the president
of the United States is corrupt and is
at the head of an organized criminal
Enterprise one of the issues there is
okay let's assume it's repayment of a
loan let me see the loan let me see the
agreement what is the schedule of
payments and you know if it wasn't a
loan then Joe Biden is still in a pickle
because if it wasn't a loan he didn't
pay taxes on
$240,000 and by the way the 40,000 is
10% of 400,000 that Hunter got from an
LLC in 2017 the same year that the
WhatsApp he said my father and I are
waiting here you know we want our $5
million so but David Weiss I mean he
said he wasn't impeded in his
investigation at all okay I don't
believe that for one second why did he
ask to be special counsel why did it
take him five years to ask to be special
counsel and why did it take him 5 years
to come up with a plea deal that was so
embarrassing that no one in the Justice
Department had ever offered it before
when I heard today that the Baltimore
Police Commissioner got jail time for
less tax evasion than Hunter Biden did
so you know David Weise is not an
innocent player here this is money
laundering and either Joe made a loan to
the family and they paid him back
through Chinese funds connected to the
Chinese uh uh uh come on can I can I ask
you a question what would be I don't I'm
not going to do business with China but
what would be wrong with that what's if
if it's a Chinese connected Communist
Party connected fuel company where they
where the heads of the government are on
the board then that's illegal no well no
tell me what's illegal I wouldn't do
that but there's I don't know what's
illegal about that he was not in office
if you think if he did give the family a
loan and they paid him back through this
money we're going to make some
assumptions what's a I don't know what's
a legal about that because they are they
are promising something in return for
that money what did they give them in
return for that you know contract law I
got so you're saying you're saying that
maybe they said we're going to give you
help in the government maybe I'm just
trying to figureure as a constitutional
legal expert I believe it's called quidd
proquo yeah which I phrase I just coined
quid pro Joe but Joe wasn't in office
all I'm I hear everything everybody
saying he was not in office so I get it
I get it I just want to get get the law
down well here it is I mean they were
paying him for what he did when he was
in office oh so they this came in right
after he was in 8 years of the White
House and he took action as vice
president and then he took action
favorable to China when he was president
it doesn't take a genius to figure it
out Harold if I can figure it out you
can figure it out here's the thing Biden
says he's a big believer in fate right
well I'm a big believer in karma and if
you lie and take bribes and hide it for
all these years it's going to come back
to bite you and and this is coming back
to bite him right now his base Biden's
is leaving at the same time comr is
closing in Joe Biden is totally exposed
here you need a strong solid big base to
defend some of these investigations Joe
doesn't have that and now I know because
I know the media better than the media
knows itself when that 40,000 10% for
the big guy came in and all I heard was
crickets from the press that tells me
they know it's bad and they're even
going to tempt to try to hide it on that
note which in a rare form Jesse makes
sense that like it it is incredible that
the med this this is basically being
spoonfed to the media this is something
you can follow and you could make a
great story but they won't well and the
and the president's staff and the
campaign staff and the lawyers their job
is to make you think this is very
complicated their job is to make you
believe that there is reasonable doubt
in the court of public opinion but I can
even do 10% math yeah right so they get
the $400,000 payment it goes into a
check-in account that has like no money
in it and then all of a sudden later
that day they get a 40% check I like
okay yeah that makes sense to me 10% for
the big gu like it's it's see Harold
women can do math I like what you said
in the break yeah and in the green room
too the other thing is I did not say
that part of the part of the quidd pro
quo was the access yeah it's just access
and it's just like that's why for
example you have powerful people on
retainer for the just in case scenario
that you might need them at some point
that it doesn't necessarily mean that
you do something specific it means I
have you on retainer in case I get
arrested and I need you to bail me out
right judge absolutely because you know
you're going to get in trouble one way
we should have a board the five should
have their own board of people on law
enforcement just in case
yes and also call Handy
yes why what why because he'll always
help you out oh that's good oh like if
you get like no I always say like if I
were to get arrested walking home
tonight you call Hannity I would call
you and I'd call Hannity and then I'd
call Peter yeah I'm way down that list
yeah well I might call you to see if
you'd take care of
Percy i' ride Percy is what I do all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else